[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis bonsoir
mirabel et son frère petit louis sont de
plus en plus sage petit louis ne suce
plus on pousse et mirabel ne n'ai plus
les doigts dans son nez lors maman est
bien content rosso oui et moi aussi je
suis bien content car il me l'avait
promis
j'espère que vous aussi les petits
enfants vous suivez leurs bons exemples
ce soir je vais vous raconter une belle
histoire et aux places en plus oui
d'accord gros ours tu descends leur
montrer le livre d'image et moi je leur
raconte l'histoire très bien patron je
prends le livre et et hop la pop aux
propos pour des soins pas trop lent
nounours ouais ouais propres propos
en fait
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits diables mais pourquoi
ne ferait on pas plutôt une partie de
bruit ou bien un petit poker encore
patron j'avais oublié non les enfants
ulysse m'a interdit de jouer aux cartes
parce qu'un jeu triste c'est bien les
enfants
je vais essayer de faire comme vous mais
je vous ai apporté un beau livre d'image
que je vais vous montrer et que ulysse
va vous raconter oui chic alors
asseyons-nous là on est bien installé
bon c'est l'histoire de la belette qui
avait perdu ses lunettes
[Musique]
quel beau livre raconte l'histoire vous
pas trop madame belette qui était fort
distraite par un beau jour de printemps
avait perdu ses lunettes
elle ne voyait plus rien la pauvrette
car elle était très myope et à se cogner
partout
que c'est détruit toutes les enfants
écouter la suite elle marcha longtemps
et arriva enfin devant une maison
qu'elle cru être la sienne en boulettes
distraite
elle avait bien sûr oublier ses clés et
elle fera pas donc à la porte
toc toc toc mais ça ne va pas d'âme
hubble est ma parole mais mais tu vois
de travers qu'as tu fait de tes lunettes
c'était monsieur l'escargot en personne
car dame hubble est bien entendu s'était
trompé de maison
si laurence les enfants elle m'intéresse
moi cette histoire je cherche ma maison
compères escargots je cherche ma maison
viendront avec moi d'un meublé est il
répondit d'escargots qui était un petit
coquin vient nous allons la chercher
ensemble et il emmena notre bonne est
distraite à travers chants très loin et
elle était bien fatiguée elle se cognait
tout le temps aux fleurs aux cailloux et
se perdaient au milieu des grands champs
de blé et elle n'arrêtait pas de répéter
mais où sont dont mes lunettes ou son
nom mes lunettes et compère escargot qui
s'amusaient comme un petit fou des
malheurs de notre pauvre belec tu rien
sous sa coquille
ils arrivèrent alors au milieu d'un
grand champlain de coquelicots et il
entend dire un bruit terrible
ce n'est pas bon on ne peut pas manger
ça
c'est trop dur ça fait mal au bec ils
s'approchèrent et découvrir un joli
petit nid plein de bébés fauve est pas
content du tout leur maman leur avait
porté à manger quelque chose de très dur
et devinez ce que c'était c'étaient les
lunettes de dames boulette ou moi j'ai
trouvé ça et j'ai cru que c'était bon à
manger dit la maman fauvettes mais en
effet vous avez raison c'est trop dur et
un plat et les jeta hors du nid et l
atterrir
vous savez où sur le nez de dames
belette mes lunettes
mes lunettes merci gentil fauvettes et
notre peuple est danser et sauter de
joie
elle était si contente qu'elle invite à
tous ses amis à dîner
sans oublier ce qu'aucun d'escargots et
ce fut une grande fête
il y eut des graines pour les petits
oiseaux et même une feuille de salade
pour ce farceur d'escargots cette
histoire merci de nous allons les
bambins au lit il est tard
nous on a gardé lee oui les enfants
merci ninon ça demain pour voir les
enfants à demain
[Musique]
non
les p'tits louis monier mirabel bonne
nuit tous les enfants aller vite au dodo
nous reviendrons vous voir demain en
vaut deux compagnons en route patron
bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh